[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
STEVE BAZYL: Hi, everyone.
I'm Steven Bazyl.
ALAIN VONGSUVANH: I'm
Alain Vongsuvanh.
STEVE BAZYL: And today, we're
going to do an app review of
what I think is actually
a really cool app.
This is InstallFree Nexus.
They actually have two versions
of this app, one with
LibreOffice, another one
with Microsoft Office.
We're going to take a look at
the LibreOffice version today.
I think it's actually
a really cool app.
Have you had a chance to play
around with this much?
ALAIN VONGSUVANH: Yeah, this
is really nice, because as
we're moving towards storing our
files in the cloud, many
of us have Legacy files
on our hard drive.
It's true that Google Docs and
Google Drive has a doc editor
which nice to use, but users
want to be able to open the
Legacy files and edit
them on the web.
STEVE BAZYL: So if you have
something where maybe the
formatting is a little too
complicated for us, then you
actually can use the real
version of those products in
the web, and it's actually
really cool.
So let's just take a look at
their Chrome listing page.
You're going to see here,
InstallFree Nexus with
LibreOffice and some
screenshots.
I already have the app
installed, so I'm not going to
go through that entire
process.
But I just wanted to show it's
a pretty well-done page here
that explains the app, and
similarly, with the Office
version as well.
Really important to have these
Chrome Web Store pages for
people to discover your apps
and explain what they do.
But really, we care about
the app itself
and some of the features.
Here I have in my drive
just a couple files
that I created earlier.
Let's just see what this
experience is like.
So let's go create a
LibreOffice file.
And you're going to see here an
interesting design issue.
And this is partly the way the
product works and partly a
limitation in the Drive SDK.
But you see here that I have to
choose what type of while I
want to create.
And I think it would be nice
if we had this in the SDK,
where we could actually--
ALAIN VONGSUVANH: Create
new presentations.
STEVE BAZYL: Exactly.
Have multiple actions
in the UI.
But right now, because they want
this to be one install
action for the users,
they have to have
this in their app.
But something we can improve
upon in the SDK, but I think
they handled it really well
given that limitation.
And let's just create a doc.
The cool thing about this is
what they're actually doing is
spinning up LibreOffice in a
virtual machine in the cloud
and giving us remote desktop,
RDP, in our browser.
That's actually kind of
mind blowing when
you think about it.
ALAIN VONGSUVANH: First time
you run it, it's just like,
whoa, you're running
a desktop?
STEVE BAZYL: Exactly.
So we have the full
version of this.
If we were doing the Office
version, we'd have just
regular Microsoft Office
running in our browser.
And we can just start
typing away.
[TYPING]
STEVE BAZYL: So not a very
exciting doc, but
let's go and save it.
And here, we'll save in our
Documents, and give it a nice
little file name.
Having a little trouble
typing today.
And it should be saving.
And here we go.
There's the file.
We have our file we created.
We can close that, open it
back up, and we should be
right back to where we did.
One of the issues with running
an app like this that is a
little heavy, the startup time
is slower than using a full
web-based editor like
Google Docs.
So you have a little bit a
trade-off in terms of startup
time versus features and
functionality, but here we are.
We're back to where we
were with our file.
Earlier I created this
directory, and this actually
goes back to a GDL that
we did last week.
It was Ali and I, and we talked
about the differences
of drive versus a file system.
And some of the issues--
one, in particular, is
disambiguating files because
we don't have this restriction
that file names are unique.
So what do you think is going to
happen when we open this up
in this directory
in LibreOffice?
ALAIN VONGSUVANH: As I can see,
you have two files with
the same name, so I guess you're
going to have a hard
time handling this, and only
show one of the two.
Which one?
I don't know.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah, Well,
that's a good question.
So let's go in here.
And you can see here, they
actually created basically a
virtual file system in Windows,
and I can just
navigate through my drive
content here.
And as you guessed, they
only show one file.
Unfortunately, I don't know
which one they've actually
shown without actually
opening this up.
So what should they
do in this case?
ALAIN VONGSUVANH: They should
show both of the files, maybe
having a way to identify that
those two files are different.
STEVE BAZYL: So putting like a
suffix on one of them with
like a version or time stamp--
ALAIN VONGSUVANH: Yeah.
STEVE BAZYL: --or something
like that?
So this is actually a pretty
significant issue.
It looks like they probably
should have about the same
time stamp.
Not entirely sure which
one that is.
ALAIN VONGSUVANH: You can
save it and see what the
new time stamp is.
STEVE BAZYL: That's true.
Let's actually do that
and see what happens.
Oh, interesting.
They're giving me--
let's modify it first
and then save it.
And, there we go.
So it was this one.
So, yeah, it's a little bit of
a wart on the user experience
there, in that if you do have
files with the same name, it's
a little bit difficult, or
actually nearly impossible, to
make sense of what happens
in that case.
The good part, though, is that
you can access the application
fully from within
the Drive UI.
They also have their own file
viewer inside their web
application which lets
you navigate.
And in this case,
they actually do
display the files correctly.
So it's just within that virtual
file system where it's
not quite handled entirely
correct.
So to make this possible, one of
the things I have to do is
request access to
all my files.
What are your thoughts
on that?
Is that the right decision
in this case?
ALAIN VONGSUVANH: We're trying
to move away from the broader
scope which gives an
app access to an
entire user's drive.
But as we are building a virtual
file system, they
don't have a choice but to
request access to another
user's drive.
One other way we could do it is
only list files they have
access to or created, but that
will limit the user experience
for the application.
STEVE BAZYL: Right.
So in that case, if they were
to do a file open from this,
all their Legacy files that
they haven't yet launched
probably wouldn't show up
in this case, right?
ALAIN VONGSUVANH: Yes.
STEVE BAZYL: So, it's an
interesting challenge for apps
like this, where they need to
have an integrated File
Explorer, but I think the value
of having this actually
behave like a real desktop
application and then look like
it has a file system probably
was the right
decision for them.
But they could have done a more
restricted version that
doesn't require as
much permission.
ALAIN VONGSUVANH: And that
uses the picker API.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah, that
would be interesting.
Any thoughts on ways that they
would be able to get the
picker to work inside a native
desktop experience like this?
ALAIN VONGSUVANH: It should be
hard, because they'll have to
fire the picker on the client
side, on the browser, and ask
the user to choose a file, and
send it back to the server.
So it won't really show as
a native file picker.
It will show with the Google
Picker API UI.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah.
I think it would be an
interesting experiment to
figure out if that
is possible.
And personally, I'm not familiar
enough with the
OpenOffice and Office APIs to
know how easy it is to plug in
or replace those menu options.
But I think it would be
something that would be a good
experiment for somebody to try
and see if that's possible.
It definitely would help a lot
on the security side to be
able to switch over
to that more
restrictive per file access.
Let's just take a quick look at
some of the other editors.
We can create another one.
What do you want to
create this time?
We can do a spreadsheet.
We can do a presentation.
ALAIN VONGSUVANH: What
do you think?
STEVE BAZYL: How about
we do a drawing?
ALAIN VONGSUVANH:
Drawing, yeah.
Never tried this one.
STEVE BAZYL: You actually have
access to the full suite.
And again, you have
the Microsoft
version of these as well.
And let's see if my art
skills are any good.
ALAIN VONGSUVANH: You
need a trackpad?
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah.
I have a feeling I'm going to do
a not so good job here, but
you can draw some lines.
Oops.
Maybe this was the wrong demo
to do, as I am not very
familiar with the OpenOffice
drawing here.
Here's some tools down here.
So we'll draw a very, very,
very simple smiley face.
ALAIN VONGSUVANH: You're
back to selecting.
STEVE BAZYL: LibreOffice is not
making me very happy here.
I have terrible, terrible
art skills.
There's my slightly happy,
slightly upset smiley face.
And we could do spreadsheets
as well, presentations.
And this actually handles not
just LibreOffice, but I think
they actually do conversions on
Microsoft formats and other
common formats as well.
So a really powerful application
for working with a
lot of files that you may have
had on your desktop before and
you're moving into the cloud.
If you're not quite ready to
convert those over to Google
Doc formats, something like
InstallFree Nexus is a really
good transitional tool to get
you into the cloud, but
without having to fully commit
to converting those into a
format that's in Google Docs.
ALAIN VONGSUVANH: But you still
get the features of
Google Drive, like sharing.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah.
ALAIN VONGSUVANH: You don't get
collaborating, but you can
share a file with another user,
and they can use the
same app as long as they have it
installed and open it with
LibreOffice as well.
STEVE BAZYL: Exactly right.
So we can share this with other
users using the same
sharing features of any
file and drive.
Once that user gets it, they'll
actually get alerted
that this file was created
by that application.
They'll have an opportunity to
install it and start taking
advantage of it.
So is there anything else
about this that you
want to show off?
I think you were curious about
be the approval screen.
ALAIN VONGSUVANH: Yes, the codes
they are requesting.
STEVE BAZYL: So let's just
take a look at that.
What we'll do is just revoke
this here temporarily.
I'll remove, and then we can go
back to Chrome Web Store,
add it back in.
And we'll do a little refresh.
So in theory, this time
I should get a prompt.
So here's the full list
of all the things
that they're accessing.
So we have account information
for single sign-on, full
access to all of
our documents.
So again, you can see just how
much data they're actually
asking for here.
All of our documents, they can
download anything, create,
move, all that stuff.
And you can see why there's
so much emphasis on moving
towards the per file scope,
because this really is a lot
of power that you're giving
the applications.
And it's really nice from a user
perspective to be able to
say I only want to give you
access to the handful of files
that are really important
for your app.
What else?
Everything else looks
pretty normal--
email address, spreadsheets,
photos and videos.
So they actually have a lot
of functionality in here.
And we haven't even really
looked at some of the photo
capabilities, but I think they
actually pull in some stuff
from Picasa and so on as well.
ALAIN VONGSUVANH: So you
can integrate in a doc.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah,
that's true.
Right.
Yeah, exactly.
Import photos into a
documentation, and so on.
So, we'll just grant access
again, and we're back to where
we started.
So what are the things you would
like to see in the app?
Is there anything other than the
issue we saw earlier with
the virtual file system?
Any features or things that
you would like them to do
differently?
ALAIN VONGSUVANH: Do you know
if they use the revision
features on Google Drive?
STEVE BAZYL: That's a really
good question.
Certainly, I haven't seen
anything within the app for
doing this.
I know some of the Office
formats have revisions built
into the file itself.
But we should be able to go into
here, for example, and
say Revisions, and it is
actually creating them.
So this is just a feature of
Drive, and I believe by
default, we do create
a new revision.
ALAIN VONGSUVANH: On
every update, yes.
STEVE BAZYL: So, they didn't
really have to do anything
special to get that.
So I can go in here
and I can do this.
Or if it's a file format that
has built-in revision history,
we can use that as well.
But it's a really amazing
app, I think.
Just the fact that this is a
remote desktop, the full
version of these applications in
a browser, and they're not
really running any special
plugins or anything.
I think it's just Canvas and
WebSockets, and it works on
Chromebooks.
It works on a full browser
like Chrome
ALAIN VONGSUVANH: As long as
you have a modem browser,
you're good to go.
STEVE BAZYL: Exactly.
And it really is just, I think,
a crucial piece in
getting people from the desktop
into the cloud and
onto truly being able to
work from any device.
The only thing I haven't
tried this on,
actually, is a mobile device.
I'm not optimistic that it's
going to be a great experience
running Office on
a mobile phone.
But it might actually be OK on
a tablet and something that
we'll give a try and let
folks know how it goes.
But definitely something I'm
really excited about, and just
an overall solid app.
They do have to fix some
technical issues.
And if you're watching our
friends at InstallFree, you
can take a look at last week's
GDL on file systems and
disambiguation and hopefully
fix that one little issue.
Any final thoughts?
ALAIN VONGSUVANH: Again, as
you've been mentioning many
times, I think this is a really
good app to have.
It helps users move away from
Legacy file systems and into
the cloud, have the files backed
up in a secure server,
and have the files accessed
everywhere.
They can use sharing to share
files instead of sending a
specific file via email, have
multiple users edit those
files using the same app, and
see what other users do on the
same file instead of sending a
file, getting it back, trying
to merge for revisions,
et cetera.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah.
So I think that's
it for today.
Thank you, everyone,
for coming, and
we'll be back on Thursday.
I don't know if the topic has
been set, but I'm sure it will
be a very good GDL again.
So, thanks for watching
and stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]